bonjour à tous est ravie de vous
retrouver et sur public sénat
tout au long du mois de septembre et
bien je vous propose de voir et de
revoir les temps forts des auditions et
de la séance lors de la dernière session
parlementaire car tout au long du mois
de septembre est bien les sénateurs sont
absents du palais du luxembourg car ils
sont en campagne il prépare les
prochaines élections sénatoriales qui se
tiendront le 28 septembre et qui
permettront de renouveler la moitié de
la haute assemblée retour aujourd'hui à
une audition qui s'est tenue le 9 avril
dernier au sénat une audition de thierry
breton ancien ministre de l'économie par
la mission commune d'information sur la
gouvernance mondiale d'internet
l'ancien ministre est aujourd'hui
président d'atos l'un des leaders de
l'informatique au niveau mondial et à ce
titre il s'était vu confier deux
missions l'une par la commission
européenne et l'autre par arnaud
montebourg alors que lui même était
encore ministre des missions portant sur
l'internet dématérialiser le fameux
cloud cet espace virtuel de stockage sur
internet ils avaient d'ailleurs livré
certaines de ses conclusions au sénat le
9 avril on les écoute madame monsieur le
sénateur
d'abord je voudrais vous dire que je
suis très honoré trouver dans cette
salle
ok je suis aller sous d'autres avec
d'autres responsabilités
et vous dire aussi que le sujet que vous
traitez nous le rapporteur est un sujet
qui me semble absolument essentiel pour
pour la nation mais aussi vous l'avait
appelé dans vos propos pour l'europe
alors c'est un sujet sur lequel on
travaille depuis très longtemps et j'ai
travaillé moi j'aime depuis très
longtemps dans le cadre de mes
différentes fonctions précédentes par
notre petit aparté au début avec eux
autres collègues sénateurs anneaux mais
nous nous rappelions que en 1993
président d'une haute est venue me
demander de contribuer à la définition
pédagogique des enseignements
l'ingénieur du futur cas de l'université
de technologie de troyes
d'où la petite aparté et pour dire que
les sujets que vous que vous traitez
sont absolument essentielles et au coeur
aussi de mes préoccupations personnelles
si vous permettez un petit point un
petit point également pour vous pour
vous dire
j'ai évidemment accepté avec
enthousiasme quand on m'a proposé de
venir le aujourd'hui j'ai trouvé que le
titre que
nouveau rôle et nouvelle stratégie pour
l'union européenne dans la gouvernance
mondiale de l'internet
était pour moi pardon de le dire comme
ça à mes un peu réducteur par rapport à
l'ambition que je crois déceler derrière
vos propos liminaire parce qu'au fond
qu'est ce que sera l'internet dans cinq
ans dans dix ans est-ce qu'il existera
encore est ce que le terme même existera
rappeler que quand on a démarré avec
philippe adnot savoir une information du
futur le mot n'existe pas encore ou à
peine dans l'internet c'est un protocole
qui permet effectivement des échanges de
données de plus en plus rapide
destockage
le sentiment moi qui m'anime est
ce que j'ai essayé d'apporter dans les
deux contributions qu'elle vous faites
allusion c'est bien entre doute là
d'internet internet aujourd'hui tu as la
main essentiellement d'eux
nous aime bien américain on voit
effectivement
y avoir un rôle mondial peut-être le
vrai sujet pour moi si vous permettez
c'est le sujet des données car au fond
d'un net permet de véhiculer des données
de les stocker de les pros ccc ça à mon
avis la réflexion de long terme il faut
je crois avoir pour notre pays et pour
le lait pour l'europe les protocoles
c'est comme si lorsque j'avais des prix
dans thomson on m'avait demandé
d'assister à une audition sur
quel est l'avenir
de mp3
coordination de mp3 voilà donc je pars
donc c'est un peu réducteur
mais volontairement ça je ne serais pas
là et je crois vraiment que le sujet
quitte absolument essentiel pour
pour nous et pour nos compatriotes c'est
vraiment le sujet des données les
données on le dit de façon un peu
caricaturale pardon de le dire comme ça
mais c'est ma conviction c'est l'heure
numérique c'est l'or noir de demain si
la richesse de demain
ces données vous avez entendu des tas de
personnes qui nous ont dit vous savez
par ailleurs
tous les 18 mois
l'activité humaine génère plus de
données que
on a généré depuis la nuit des temps
jusqu'à jusqu'à aujourd'hui donc 7,7 du
caractère exponentiel de la génération
des données la nécessité également leur
traitement dans la capsule de stockage
parfaitement et puis derrière vous avez
effectivement tout ce qui va autour
en termes de création de richesses
d'innovation les algorithmes qui vont
permettre de les traiter le profiling
pour les individus et cetera et cetera
donc on le voit nous mêmes du reste de
nos activités ce qui est le cas
aujourd'hui le véritable moteur de
l'innovation véritable moteur de
l'innovation c'est dans cette économie
numérique qui s'annonce c'est la
proximité de ces données permettent
finalement de donner un usage à l'accès
à ces données à toutes les start up
innovateurs à tous ceux qui vont vouloir
précisément offrir des nouveaux services
à valeur ajoutée pour nos compatriotes
pour nos concitoyens mais aussi pour les
entreprises et cette proximité
cet accès est absolument essentielle et
c'est vrai il ya une différence avoir un
accès à des données qui sont localisés
dans un environnement qui vous est
proche ou donné qu'ils sont de localiser
ailleurs
dans d'autres environnements avec
d'autres régulation d'autres éléments de
contrôle et on y revient on revient
exactement sur ce sujet
qui pour moi va vraiment animé dans le
cadre alors si vous permettez je vais
commencer à parler de la mission donc
que je mène avec d'une chien peut qu'y
le coprésident de sf de la sape et puis
ensuite celle que m'a confiée
le ministre donc de l'économie
d'entassement productif et du numérique
sur sur
le cloud en faut en france et la façon
de le dynamiser et de permettre son son
essor d'abord avec un avec mon collègue
co président de s&p nous avons été fait
partie d'un
open cloud partnership pardon de
l'anglicisme on ne rapporte pas
l'anglais donc c'est le sait le board
donc qui réunit
hubert tardieu qui m'accompagne
suisse et à faire donc pour moi à
bruxelles une trentaine de participants
dont une entreprise pardon je vous ai
pas présenté mais de
deux collaborateurs dont gilbert
tardieux donc qui est le patron de la
communauté scientifique chez atos qui
vire tout nous tous nos pays riches dit
elle aux scientifiques et olivier unis
qui après avoir été directeur de cabinet
du président de l'assemblée qui n'était
pas le sénat et maintenant mon directeur
de cabinet
au sein d'atos et suit notamment les
aspects qu'on a développée avec
monsieur montebourg est ce que là bas
qui est le co
président de la mission sur le cloud
donc avec libertaire du effectivement on
a en a on a vraiment essayé de de
travailler avec nos collègues européens
donc à l'initiative des délits crous sur
7 sur cette affaire et en essayant de
définir un générer un cadre à cadre
européen on appelle ça on appelait ça
entre nous un espace de confiance pour
pour permettre au cloud de se développer
derrière le cloud évidemment il ya
l'aspect des données alors là on a
commencé par dire pas dire quelque chose
d'assez simple on a et on essaie
vraiment de développer cette c'était cet
état d'esprit au fond c'est les données
des européens doivent être stockés
traité procès c'est en europe on est
ouverts quand ils trouvèrent on peut
l'accepter on vient de les traiter les
poux conviennent anticiper à ce
traitement et processing si certains ont
des des innovations technologiques pour
accroître les capacités de stockage en
deux algorithmes sophistiqués pour
permettre de les mettre en cohérence
très bien on est ouvert et que l'europe
est un continent qui t'a continent qui
doit être ouvert aux innovations aux
investissements mais il ya une chose
qu'il veut être certaine il a je pense
que là dessus il ne faut pas transiger
nos données nous appartiennent et on en
a même la responsabilité
donc c'est quelque chose de simple on a
utilisé du reste cette cette notion un
peu ensuite avec nos collègues y en a il
faudrait un peu une politique d'optimum
en a développé lors de la mise en oeuvre
de schengen c'est à dire des pays qui
adoptent un 2/3 des pays pionniers une
même approche
et les opr des baux régulatrice
de la façon dont on traite en somme nos
données et puis va sur l'a6 jamais notre
rêve au fond on a vu prise de relance a
parlé on doit voir madame merkel si
l'allemagne et la france adopte une
approche identique pense que ça va faire
des émules et que de deux trois quatre
pays vont peut-être avoir la même
approche en ce qui concerne donc cet
aspect des choses on veut surtout pas
lors des débats on avait démarré du
reste notre réflexion avant même que les
révélations de l'été dernier
john parle évidemment des révélations de
monsieur snowdon donne un angle plus
particulier donc sur les données
beaucoup s'en sont émus
mais il est clair que nous avions
démarré notre réflexion et notre action
bien avant cela on n'est pas du tout
dans une dans une logique où on essaie
de réagir par rapport à des événements
on pense que c'est notre responsabilité
c'est la responsabilité des
représentants
peuple que vous n'êtes que de ce
vraiment les législateurs de se
préoccuper de cette question et d'avoir
d'avoir quelques quelques idées peut
être simple mais mais mais assez ferme
au fond est-ce qu'on imaginerait que
les données essentielles des chinois
soient traitées en dehors de chine
pense qu'aujourd'hui ce serait est-ce
qu'on imaginerait que les données
financières des américains ou de données
d'impôt de america soit traité en france
en belgique
ou ailleurs donc il ya des pays qui ont
des réactions assez clair là dessus et
puis il ya un continent qui est un peu
plus
manque de coordination qui prend un peu
de temps or il faut aller vite
quand on regarde l'évolution de façon
dont
la richesse économique s'est créé au
cours des cours des siècles
on a commencé par traiter l'espace
territorial et puis on a régulé l'espace
territorial pour mieux le réglementer
créer des richesses étaient partagés
après ça ça a été l'espace r il ya
l'espace maritime
et puis l'espace aérien est désormais
c'est désormais c'est l'espace
informationnel il faut aussi en prendre
possession il faut aussi avoir le
courage de le réglementer pas trop en
tout cas d'avoir des règles communes et
ça c'est la première d'entre elles donc
on est vraiment là dessus vraiment
on voudrait avoir un rôle et je suis
ouvert évidemment aux pouvoirs publics
français
on a eu un peu de mal au début les
aligner
mais je dois dire que après quelques
quelques quelques périodes qui était un
peu erratique on a maintenant un bon
alignement des positions françaises
d'ivoire le français hubert avec les
positions tout déviation de défendre au
niveau 2 de l'europe dans le cadre
encore une fois de cette de cette
commission
donc je le répète première chose essayer
de faire en sorte que nous créions un
espace de confiance
donc au niveau d'aidé des pays qui
voudraient qu'ils voudraient adopter
cette cette approche
une deuxième chose c'est évidemment le
fait que la protection de ces données
ne doit pas être je dirais une façon
unique mais au contraire adapté à leur
nature et leur usage des données qui
sont faites sans importance elle a
d'autres dont on estime qu'elles sont
plus importantes
l'e santé l'e qui correspondent à son
patrimoine fiscalité
ce qui concerne le secteur veut les
secteurs financier bancaire
rappelle que vous allez avoir une
échéance importante avec l'évolution de
swift en 2015 on était parfaitement au
courant de cela j'imagine
donc donc on a en a défini un certain
nombre voilà des données on avait bronze
silver gold jargon bien d'acquisition
moins importantes que d'autres on peut
il se permettre on peut éventuellement
c'est pas de problème qu'elle soit parce
que finalement vos consommations de
musique vos morceaux de musique préférés
est ce que ça peut être été dans le
serveur du nebraska
peut-être
les de santé peut-être pas donc voilà il
faut quand même qu'on est là dessus
quelque chose une approche donc on a
segmenté de façon assez simple et puis
en faisant centre on se positionne le
dernier élément qui est important c'est
celle éléments de la confiance on le
voit aujourd'hui notamment après la
révélation de l'été dernier beaucoup
d'entreprises d'acteurs et acteurs
économiques voire de gouvernement hésite
un peu à passer en mode cloud le cloud
c'est évidemment une une évolution très
importante puisque ça permet la
mutualisation de l'infrastructure
informatique
les capacités de stockage la
virtualisation ensuite état qui est
associé donc pour pouvoir traiter sur
des mêmes fermes de serveurs
des applications différentes pour des
clients différents et donc de réduire
les coûts très sensiblement d'augmenter
la capacité de traitement la rapidité de
stockage et puis surtout de passer en
paiement à l'usagé était extrêmement
important et non plus de faire supporter
par les clients les investisseurs les
les autres les entreprises ou les
gouvernements ou les collectivités
locales le poids de l'investissement
mais évident de passer en pay per use
ses adhérents paiement à usage général
instance a posé pas une des questions de
tva quand on applique ensuite à l'emploi
en france par rapport
aux dépenses d'investissement et aux
dépenses de fonctionnement mais jamais
dans un instant donc sur le niveau
européen sur ce soit question des choses
cette question on se rend compte qu'il
ya eu un peu de réticence et fond il
faut aller vite la compétitivité passe
aussi beaucoup beaucoup par sly de plus
en plus part cela le fait qu'on ait des
ddd système qui soit pas harmonisés et
différence de régulation entre la france
entre l'allemagne entre la belgique
luxembourg et autres on voit bien par
exemple que nous ne pouvons pas traiter
aujourd'hui on va voir on est un groupe
européen par les atos tout
donc on est présent dans tous les pays
européens on est leader en europe on m'a
si on veut faire bénéficier nos clients
de des infrastructures de cloud par
exemple même des clients gouvernementaux
pas on peut pas sur des données même
simple il faut qu'on ait des serveurs
d'à côté du rhin le cerveau l'autre côté
du rhin peut pas ne pas d'harmonisation
ça aussi c'est un manque de
compétitivité au fond on se rend bien
compte que que quand on dit qu'il faut à
qui nous font plaide pour un espace de
confiance au niveau européen avec des
qualités de sécurité
des services on appelle ça en anglais
les services level agreements est à dire
d comme on peut dire ça en français
niveau de service garantie niveau de
service garantie donc qui sont précisés
pour pouvoir on dit également que au
fond devenir opérateur de données en
termes de capacité de stockage et
traitement de den heede processing de
ces données c'est pas ne s'est pas une
fonction anodine et donc nous on plaide
pour avoir une sorte de licence pour le
faire voilà c'est pas anodin de traiter
les données de ses compatriotes c'est
quelque chose voilà il faut il faut une
licence de croix pour un débit de
boissons nous sommes que d'avoir une
licence pour un traitement de données se
serait pas complètement
surréaliste que de demander et ça c'est
quelque chose et donc encore au niveau
repères si deux trois quatre pays adopte
ce même ces mêmes niveaux de service
minimum pour pouvoir opérer des fermes
de serveurs en mode cloud par exemple ça
serait à plus très important
voilà donc
et et nous demandons du reste qui est un
droit de contrôle effectif que vous
ferez sans peut accueillir n'importe qui
et on va oublier le patriot act et autre
chose on peut accueillir n'importe qui
je pense qu'on pouvoir traiter ces
données mais si vous venez les traités
sur le territoire européen il faut
peut-être quelque part avant une sorte
de permis de conduire le faire c'est à
dire on applique la loi européenne et
pas d'autres lois ah oui mais ça ne
dépend que de nous ça ne dépend que de
nous
moi je suis dans son pays européenne
j'ai beaucoup pillant quillan me voir
parce que je suis entreprises
européennes je comprenais parfaitement
ce que je veux dire
donc ça ne dépend que de nous c'est il
faut qu'on impose que voilà quand on
traite des données en europe c'est la
loi européenne ces deux lois françaises
la télé rhji ce serait l'idéal
évidemment de 3,4 pays qui adoptent le
même type de régulation sur ces données
qui s'applique et aucune autre et on
sait qu'à ce moment là mais donné qu'en
cd confie c'est l'espace de confiance
quand je les confie je sais qu'elles
sont
dépendent une voie que je connais et
donc j'accepte d'autant mieux de les
confier en confiance
c'est un c'est un sujet qui est
absolument essentiel 1 et là on voit
évidemment que quand on discute de tout
cela et les uns et les autres ont des
approches différentes
les lobbys des approches différentes je
pense que là il faut il faut essayer
d'être d'être fermé c'est vraiment
maintenant qu'il convient le faire
évidemment dans cette dans cette
approche le franco-allemand est
absolument essentiel nous avons vu nos
amis allemands depuis l'été dernier sera
fermé un peu sur eux mêmes donc je pense
qu'il est important d'être à
l'initiative viala vraiment un accès mon
avis de coopération franco-allemande est
absolument essentielle si nous adoptions
une approche à peu près similaire
ensemble ce serait un très grand pas qui
pourrait te faire mon avis assez
rapidement
et qui ont la vue vers qui permettrait à
d'autres de suivent ensuite ils nous ont
dit très clairement le couple
franco-allemand ici à mon avis pourrait
être un élément moteur dans cette danse
est
je lirai régulation de l'espace de 2 0l
très ouvert évidemment nous avons ouvert
on n'est pas naïf on pourra pas mettre
des lignes maginot c'est pas le sépare
la question la question c'est encore une
fois de dire que nos données de tout
traité procès en europe n'importe où
s'ils ont des régulations simple
identique pour tous avec des mêmes
niveaux de sécurité je résume mais bien
sûr j'aurai des questions je répondrai à
vos questions si vous le souhaitez
entendu sur cette synthèse que des
choses on a bien avancé on a remis
maintenant rapporte quasiment finalisé
hubert analyser et et la consultation
publique maintenant sur sur ces aspects
mais il faut que vous sachiez que
par notre présence il celle d'hubert qui
est à mes côtés la france a été très
moteur dans cette affaire très moteur on
a été vraiment très très moteur et et on
a je crois finalement réussi à
entraîner un peu l'ensemble de nos
des partis pendant que tu es avec nous y
compris nos amis britanniques avaient
quand même les difficultés de nos amis
irlandais c'est un peu plus compliqué
mais enfin voilà il ya en tout cas en
europe continentale clairement une
position une position à jouer je pense
qu'il serait formidable que les les
autorités publiques et politiques de
notre pays s'en empare désormais
les industriels que nous sommes seront
derrière évidemment
voilà pour le
lion panne cloud partnership est donc la
publication du document de travail donc
qui a été réalisée le 21 mars 2014 qui
sera vos dispositions évidemment je
pense que vos services sont utilisateurs
l'accès donc on sera à vos dispositions
pour le commenter pendant vos questions
si vous le souhaitez non ce qui concerne
la deuxième aspect des choses alors
c'était intéressant parce qu'on a fait
deux approches pratiquement parallèle
donc on n'a plus du reste avant une
bonne harmonie donc sur le sur le cloud
que m'avait confié arnaud arnaud
montebourg voit comme avec le président
de dow vh taf klaba donc là on a fait
une proche donc j'étais évidemment
comment faire dans le cadre des trente
quatre plans de la nouvelle france
industrielle comment faire pour
bur dynamiser
le cloud évidemment avec la proche à la
fois d'innovations industrielles et
d'emploi puisque c'est un peu le
triptyque qui anime donc
arnaud montebourg dans son dans sa
volonté de
développer ses 34 plan pour la nouvelle
france industrielle
voilà donc donc on a travaillé avec une
très large consultation donc l'ensemble
des acteurs français un travail
important là qu'ils étaient tous mené
par olivier
de tessa donc
fait tout ça à bercy
ça nous demander beaucoup de temps
un très bon niveau de coordination et on
a maintenant un document qui est
finalisé on a remis dressera janvier
je crois qu'il n'est pas encore
publiquement fond je pense qu'il n'y
aura aucun problème pour que vous en
ayez connaissance je pense qu'on
communiqué
qu'il y aie aie aie aie a pas de
problème et vous verrez que ce ont ce
document est assez et lci exhaustif je
vais le résumé donc d'une part en ce qui
concerne donc l'homme il a aussi redonné
confiance
donc pour pour permettre à l'ensemble
des entreprises françaises aussi des
agents économiques de plus en plus de
faire appel aux op là où d'un donc une
labellisation
secure cloud c'est à dire faire en sorte
que
là encore lorsque on opère en mode cloud
sur le territoire français c'est le
pendant de ce que j'ai dit au niveau on
perd on a un niveau de labellisation et
7 je dirais que
c'est l'équivalent on a permis de permis
d'opérer avec façon à ce qu'on est on
est vraiment cet élément de confiance
qui est absolument essentiel pour
pouvoir passer en mode cloud y faire en
sorte qu'un acteur économique un agent
économique confie ses données le
traitement de ces données à un tiers il
faut ce qu'il faut que ce tiers soit un
tiers de confiance il faut qu'on ait
quand même un certain nombre d'éléments
nous avons insisté aussi sur le
développement de dab store
d'applications pour les collectivités
locales un peu à l'image de ce qu'a fait
avec un certain succès le gouvernement
britannique avec le g cloud donc on
pense que c'est un très bon exemple des
nouvelles très très grand acteur
là des premières en grande bretagne on
travaille énormément avec le
gouvernement britannique tous et toutes
ses admirations et on a contribué à
mettre beaucoup de ces applications donc
en ligne pour les collectivités locales
britanniques on pense que là il ya un
champ tout à fait intéressant
dans un ailleurs évidemment de our
essayer de trouver de la sphère de
l'économie tout va continuer à augmenter
la qualité de service et qui était de
service public il ya là jeu un jeu
formidable on le fond commence à se
faire un peu il ya des régions comme la
région bourgogne on travaille à l'autre
on développe des app stores on le fait
pour l'un c'est quand même formidable
qu'on puisse le faire sur tout le monde
ait la capacité de du cloud à nous
permet de le faire je dirais à moindre
coût quasiment en temps réel et sans
supporter du coût d'investissement donc
qui tout à fait
important pour les collectivités locales
même si
on avait on avait identifié évidemment
mais ce ne sera pas le fait de passer en
cloud notamment pour la gestion de
collectivités locales avec des
applications qui sont quasiment toutes
faites
la preuve de tva parce qu'évidemment on
est un investissement pour la récupérer
et quand vous êtes en fonctionnement
vous l'a récupérée par et nous on aime
bien sûr maintenant cloud en
fonctionnement donc il ya il ya un petit
sujet qu'il faut vraiment traité qui est
un frein est du reste été rime pas ce
que vous avez même des collectivités qui
nous disent
enfin bien mais c'est faire des
économies mais
là je récupère la tva donc ça
m'intéresse plus voilà donc on voit que
notre système fiscal n'est pas incitatif
aller dans une solution qui est ce qui
permet de réaliser des économies comme
peut-être quelque chose de même quelques
jeux d'enfants l'a signalé à mais je
vous le dis parce qu'évidemment je
connais un petit peu bercy également
avoir quelques réticences c'est un peu
combat mon avis qui me semble être un
combat bon combat à mener pour nous pour
nos économies et pour pour les
collectivités locales ont la filiale air
dur et ça c'est quelque chose qui figure
à notre notre apport voilà donc
sur sur le
site en question c'est juste juste qu'on
a on a également
défini donc
à tout un écosystème des critères pour
que l'écosystème sont favorables au
niveau du cloud les problèmes aussi de
l'investissement les opérer des plates
formes de cloud s'était hissé très
consommateurs d'énergie c'est un peu
électro intensifs donc donc on a il ya
sans doute des choses à faire là aussi
et la france a été pendant longtemps un
pays qui est très attractif en matière
énergétique notamment par rapport à sa
politique nucléaire et grâce à sa
politique nucléaire
il nous faut on il faut
on commence à voir que autour des
centrales nucléaires il ya certainement
des choses à faire pour pouvoir avoir
des lieux privilégiés de deux
traitements donnés en mode cloud ça
consomme énormément d'énergie je le
rappelle c'est des plateformes comme des
plateformes amazon ou google c'est
débile de 10000 habitants consommation
donc c'est débile cesser ces éléments
très importants il ya besoin d'avoir une
continuité et une qualité de courant une
très bonne qualité de courant sans saute
c'est effectivement ce que permet notre
parc nucléaire français
on peut avoir une bonne prévision du
prix des qualités évidemment par
définition linéaire et sans pic donc
c'est parfaitement adapté on a
aujourd'hui en tout cas avec le le
patrimoine nucléaire qui est le nôtre on
a certainement une carte à jouer très
intéressante par rapport à d'autres pays
qui sont soumis complet dans des
énergies des énergies renouvelables qui
n'aiment pas la même qualité de courant
qui ne pas les mêmes même prédictabilité
pour ce type d'activité donc c'est une
carte on verra si si on sera toujours
comme ça dans 50 ans mais en tout cas
pour les dix ou vingt ans qui viennent
on serait en train toujours à 50% au
moins de production d'autres courants
électriques en nucléaire il ya
certainement une carte à jouer et je
pense que là aussi mais qu'on l'a vu
aussi en matière de réindustralisation
comme d'autres dans d'autres sujets avec
peut-être la possibilité d'avoir une
des tarifs des tarifs qui permettent
d'attirer ce type de ce type d'activité
voilà on a aussi des filiales et les
choses comme les plates formes tremplin
à destination des éditeurs de logiciels
c'est important effectivement on a une
bonne activité d'éditeur de logiciels en
france mais qui quand elle relativement
petit il faut les aider à migrer sur le
cloud différentes routes
intervenir pour pouvoir les aider dans
cette migration petit financièrement
trouver dépouillé faut trouver des
moyens des moyens intéressants pour
pouvoir précisément leur permettre la
loi de bénéficier à la capacité
démultiplier de distribution en passant
en mode cloud mais là ils sont infinies
sont un peu réticents pour le faire
parce que c'est des investissements qui
sont assez importants je pense que
l'état pourrait là pour jouer un rôle
peut être intéressant important dans
cette transition
j'ai résumé un peu rapidement je m'en
excuse mais voilà les deux les deux
volets sur lesquels nous travaillons et
nous vous remercions nous allons vous
poser forcément quelques questions en
compliments s'agissant des données vous
nous avez vu un petit peu réagir parce
que forcément c'est au coeur de notre
réflexion c'est d'ailleurs un sujet que
nous avions évoqué plus tard dans la
commission des affaires européennes et
comme vous nous n'avons pas attendu la
ferme moderne pour nous préoccuper de
cette question qui me semblait
éminemment
stratégique s'agissant de la protection
des données comment peut-on assurer un
service sécurisé du cloud donc l'europe
ne maîtrise pas tout la pile matérielles
et logicielles qui soutient ce service
saas une première question nous avons la
deuxième question elle résulte de la
symétrie qu'il existe entre nos
juridictions européennes et américaines
et la mainmise que peuvent avoir les
états unis sur des données il comprit
stockées en
europe
de ce point de vue comment analysez-vous
le projet de règlement européen sur
lequel il ya encore beaucoup de
discussions est ce que vous pourriez
nous nous de nous en donner une
appréciation par rapport aux objectifs
que vous vous mettez légitimement en
avant il répond t-il justement à cette à
cet objectif voilà pour verser à une
question sur les données se fera que
c'est une question importante
de la question qui a monté la première
fois vous faites référence directement
au patriot act en fait et
alors qui est un sujet moi je vous le
dis en tant qu'
on va laisser aux acteurs publics le
soin de s'exprimer cette question je ne
suis plus un acteur public donc je vais
exprimer en tant que que chef
d'entreprise et est
également en tant que prestataire de
traitement de données pour le compte de
mes clients je vous direz vous dire que
là pour le coup la suze et kiki qui
passe sans cesse croissante il ya une
préoccupation maintenant systématique
systématique de la part de nos clients
européens sur cette question c'est à
dire
d'abord pour eux leur propre patrimoine
informationnel applicatifs
leur proposent leurs propres
informations
mais aussi pour beaucoup d'entre eux le
nord faisant près ce pont stabilité
vis-à-vis de leurs clients et pas
uniquement du secteur bancaire bien sûr
le secteur bancaire mais également
l'autre et donc on est on est un terreau
nous sommes interrogés
quasiment systématiquement maintenant
sur les relations vont avoir sur le
risque que cette législation
particulière peut faire courir et puis
sur leurs propres responsabilités
par rapport à l'or leurs propres clients
on prend l'exemple du secteur bancaire
voilà il ya un secret bancaire d certain
nombre de garanties vous êtes couverts
par une voix requis connu samedi
régulation qui est connu et aux opérés
et puis les clients veulent savoir ce
qui ce qui peut se passer donc cette
question d'une question absolument
essentiel et je crois qu'il est
absolument indispensable que l'union
européenne prenne une position ferme sur
cette question voilà je trouve qu'on
n'est pas encore assez ferme répondre
clairement à votre question je pense que
c'est un sujet qui va devenir absolument
essentiel alors nos amis américains en
sont conscients
je pense qu'il commence à
se dire qu'il va sans doute falloir
évoluer les choses je pense que la
période est favorable pour avoir ouvrir
une discussion bilatérale avec eux sur
cette question
mais là aussi
il serait à mon avis absolument
essentiel d'arrivée d'arrivée groupée
et je le redis je suis un peu inquiet de
voir depuis quelques mois
l'allemagne fait un peu cavalier seul
sur ces questions
donc je pense qu'il ya vraiment une
je le redis une nécessité d'un
croisement de deux
les relations franco allemandes sur
cette question est qui va pour moi bien
au delà c'est pour ça que je me suis
permis une petite digression au début
mes propos qui va au delà de l'internet
ou l'internet internet européens
d'internet franco allemand ou new
collège je pense que c'est vraiment un
sujet qui est beaucoup plus profond le
star et qui dépasse de beaucoup le
simple cadre de l'internet donc là je
pense qu'on n'est pas encore on n'est
pas encore assez
justement nous avons rencontré nos
homologues au bundestag à berlin parce
qu'il a bien conscience de l'importance
de cet axe franco allemand ils sont dans
une même réflexion
évoquant justement l'allemagne comment
avez vous compris l'appel de madame
merkel à la constitution d'un internet
européen je pense qu'il ya deux choses
il ya d'abord le stockage via les flux
alors sur le stockage ce dont parle
et
pour des raisons sans doute historique
l'allemagne quand une son histoire
récente en particulier
à une relation très
j'allais dire passionnée et passionnelle
problème de la protection des données
voilà et donc
politiquement mais
je pense que madame merkel en
particulier elle aussi voilà donc il
fallait voilà moi j'ai perçu ça que
j'allais voir une réponse un peu
politique c'est un peu de tout ce qui
nous gêne là parce que
comme le rappelait tout à l'heure vous
avez démarré cette réflexion avant
sölden l'homme est arrivé c'est dans une
autre connotation on n'est pas morts on
n'est pas en mode de réaction on est on
aime tout simplement parce qu'on fait
notre travail les uns et les autres dans
ce fameux quatrième espace vous allez
avoir à le réguler comme vous réguler
législateurs des trois premiers jeux ce
cas d'espèce il ya des sénateurs
spécialiste du droit maritime je pense
qu'elle est spéciale droit et rien d'une
sénateurs et sénatrices pays le droit et
rien il falloir qu'ils les spécialistes
du droit informationnelle et pas
internet informationnel c'est ça le
nouveau 2 donc il va falloir perdre et
en allemagne ben on a répondu un peu
les élections c'était à la réponse qui
est un peu politique et enfin c'est
comme ça que j'ai ressenti alors ceci
dit c'est parfaitement faisable
on peut avoir
des skis concerne la gestion des flux
donc et donc l'internet aujourd'hui qui
le gère qui leur est dû qu il régule et
on préfère appeler sa gestion des flux
chez nous parce qu'encore une fois il
est allé aux nouvelles qui vont arriver
plutôt qu'internet la gestion des flux
avec les routeurs et les opérateurs
télécoms j'ai été un homme dans ma
jeunesse président france télécom
également donc je connais peu ce sujet
voilà on peut on peut fonds pourrait
très bien faire comme le font les
américains du reste pour le fond du
chinois par ailleurs c'est-à-dire
demandé à ce que les routeurs soit
localisée sur le territoire leur père
est et qu'il incombe aux règles
européennes font les routards américains
et sur le télévision de territoire
américain cependant être utilisé
ailleurs bon bah voilà c'est ça la
toilette européen il suffit de dire ça
si vous dites ça vous avez répondu à
l'internet européen
que les routeurs
mais non même des routeurs chinois il
faut vérifier vous faites à l'intérieur
je vois que madame madame et connais
bien oui oui vous avez voilà oui mais
enfin
là on en revient la question du patriot
act
ou son équivalent de notre côté - moi
moins visibles mais voilà en tout cas
que c'est que c'est que c'est
la cites c'est curieux parce que on est
dans un monde qui est totalement
délocalisée
globalisé et dématérialisés
enfin pour les données la territorialité
que ce soit pour le stockage ou pour le
flux bah ça existe et il y aura pas
d'autre solution je pense qu'il faut
avoir la force de le dire et de ne pas
apparaître du reste comme des
rétrogrades jeu suffit de faire
continent de 565 millions d'habitants on
fait comme le fais un continent 2
380 ou à un autre de 1 milliard voilà on
fait la même chose pour nos propres
concitoyens compatriotes
ça c'était pour la première la deuxième
question et quant à la première pardon
je vais
le projet de règlement mais je crois que
c'est ce que vous avez évoquées et puis
c'était le fait que pour l'instant
l'europe ne nous semble pas maîtriser
toute la pile matériel aujourd'hui que
constitue de services du cloud voilà
comment on résout cette question oui bah
bah bah ça c'est
aujourd'hui
les routeurs deviennent peas n'ont pas
eu valeur de biens des ce qu'on appelle
en anglais des commodities pratiquement
assez enlevé tout à l'heure qui sera pas
brillant auteur de main rien
de plus en plus d'entreprises chinoises
c'est vrai on en a encore une ou deux en
europe qui restent mais moi moi je pars
d'un principe ou
les technologies à qu'elles soient du
reste au niveau applicatif couches
logicielles ou matérielles
sont
ce qu'elles sont il faut pour pouvoir
les utiliser sur un territoire donné
demandé à ce qu'elle répond dans un
certain nombre de normes et puis après
ça on regarde ce qui se passe et de
contrôle nous de dire on va interdire
les routeurs chinois on va interdire les
auteurs je ne sais quoi parce qu'on fait
suffisamment on procès d'intention à
prix bas si si vous mettez en europe
voilà et puis si jamais on se rend
compte que la voilà ce que vous encourez
je pense que là il faut on pourra on a
besoin de technologies et tout le monde
a pu noter que le duel est ouverte et
les mondiale alors on va pas se recréer
des technologies j'ai eu à gérer dans ma
carrière la fin du plan calcul c'était
dur voilà au nom d'une indépendance
voilà on gère des situations qui sont
absolument intenable il vaut mieux
être un espace qui est moderne réguler
ouvert mais avec une régulation assez
clair assez forte et puis que l'on
l'utilisent pour mieux ensuite contrôlés
que ceux qui vont vouloir opérer on les
force pas mais si vous venez installer
vos systèmes chez nous voilà ce que ils
doivent permettre de faire et voilà ce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas faire mais
derrière on découvre toujours on a
toujours découvrir si ce qui se passe
donc je préfère avoir un contrôle a
priori
et a posteriori pardon que que que de
dire que d'avoir fait un procès
d'intention a priori parce que
finalement
ça c'est la compétitivité dans un monde
ouvert et demander les technologies de
l'information est un monde ouvert
de territoires qu'ils vont appliquer
pour appliquer ce type de ce type d'
approche qui va en pâtir tout de suite
on est obligé effectivement d'accepter
les technologies du monde entier on est
aussi
obligé de ne pas être naïf et d'avoir
des régulations qui vont bien
quel bilan vous tirer du grand emprunt
dans son financement des deux projets de
classe de français savoir que la droite
et énergie et puis peut-être une autre
question
vous avez dit que notre industrie des
télécoms brûlé et que nous regardions
ailleurs donc
concrètement beaucoup d'amis quelles
seraient les grands axes
voilà d'une politique aujourd'hui
efficace pour reprendre un peu la main
sur ces sujets
bon sur le grand emprunt
sur les trous tout pas en parler parce
qu'ils ont les audi viennent de démarrer
je crois qu'ils ont encore un nombre
assez limité de clients y vient on a vu
papa de vomissements mais c'est pas un
peu mais enfin c'est quand même pas
encore énorme
bon enfin en tout cas
vous savez
vous avez compris que je pensais que il
vaut mieux avoir un bon système des
règles de droit qui sont claires plutôt
que que d'avoir des marges qui sont qui
sont protectionnistes qui ne marche
jamais donc voilà donc je préfère ne pas
faire le droit appliqué à tous à
des démarches
le cloud s'ouvre à je sais pas trop ce
que ça veut dire donner l'exemple nous
nous effectuerons
pour le gouvernement chinois à hong kong
nous effectuons sur notre brave au cloud
cloud souverain c'est nous qui les
faisons nos systèmes de logiciels
la comptabilité l'appelle le contrôle
d'accès en chine
les transports sur le professeur cloud
pour tous le gouvernement chinois hong
voilà donc j'imagine c'est pas cloud
souvent et pourtant c'est une société
française qui le fait et croyez moi qu
on le fait avec des règles extrêmement
strictes et qu' il n'est pas question
qu'on ne se plie pas aux régulations
qu'on nous impose
voilà donc c'est une réponse à
au cloud souverain y compris dans des
pays
qui sont pour lequel ces questions sont
absolument
essentielles
vous faites me semble c'est pourquoi ce
que vous faites me semble absolument
essentiel
alors
oui j'avais j'avais écrit c'était
puisque vous faites référence à cette
tribune que j'avais fait dans le monde
avec les normands de sécurité de respect
ce que le titre que j'avais mis de
rester vraiment notre industrie des
télécoms brûle et nous regardons
ailleurs c'était lorsque
le gouvernement précédent avait décidé
ce que j'estime être une énorme erreur
je dédie du reste ici pendant sa tribune
c'est à dire de troyer une quatrième
licence d'opérateur de
télécommunications mobiles
c'était je crois monsieur fillon ce qui
était premier ministre à l'époque et et
qui a permis à effectivement un
quatrième opérateur donc de saisir
l'opportunité qui lui était offerte pour
avoir un 4ème opérateur en france
tu ton que j'avais quelques tribunes
notre mission et télécoms brûle nous
regardons en arrière paraphraser a à
peine un public que j'ai servi moi même
et
à l'époque et est située parce que dans
le monde la tribune s'est retrouvé sous
le titre free menace l'innovation en
france donc je ne sais pas quel hacker
l'article vous avez pas ce que je vois
qu'il ya eu
mais c'était un article initial
effectivement m'ont proposé des poètes
ou parler de free beauté de parler du
régulateur même si effectivement il y a
on a bénéficié bon le sujet est assez
simple et as je pense que la régulation
du secteur des télécoms dans son
ensemble que ce soit en france et en
europe a été une tragédie
je pense c'est une terrible erreur
on a une centaine d'opérateurs de
télécoms est évidemment en europe contre
quatre aux états unis et en chine bien
sûr on va vous dire parce que les
lobbies sont très bien préparés ils ont
tous mes collaborateurs pour beaucoup
d'entre nous on se connaît bien
ah oui mais à quatre ou cinq opérateurs
on apprend on à 80 % de parts de marché
est très bien sauf que aujourd'hui on a
un système qui est totalement
destructeur de valeur et que nous sommes
il ya 20 ans
si monsieur le sénateur lorsqu on
réfléchissait au bond de demain notre
technologie d'information la france
était leader et l'europe et idieder et
la france je me souviens d'avoir été le
premier en trois présences thomson à
mettre les premières expériences de
télévision sur adsl j'étais pris dans
thomson je l'avais fait à l'époque avec
syrte juric présent alcatel et martin
bouygues président de tf1 on est de 699
on a présenté les premières expériences
de télévision sur adsl en europe je me
souviens en tant que besoin de france
télécom avoir déployé dans le cadre du
plan
donc qu'on a déployé sur l'ensemble de
l'ensemble du territoire national les
réseaux des réseaux dsl pour permettre
d'avoir la télévision sur les réseaux
qui permet ensuite le triple play je me
souviens évidemment la france et premier
inventeur du gsm bon voilà donc on a
quand même des choses formidables et
puis aujourd'hui
notre industrie des télécoms elle sert à
quoi à financer la dette que des
personnes physiques ont contracté pour
pouvoir devenir l'opérateur de la bia
public donc donc je vois bien que les
capacités aujourd'hui de financement et
je jugement sur les uns sur les autres
c'est notre système de régulation les
capacités de financement et
d'investissement que nous avons
créés dans ces indices les télécoms sont
réduites comme peau de chagrin alors que
nous sommes avait à laval
la veille une vague absolument essentiel
gigantesque
d'investissement
pour le haut débit dans les réseaux de
fibre pour la 5g on parle de la 5ème
maintenant c'était les états unis la
semaine dernière tout le monde parle de
la 5g états unis vont redevenir un pays
extrêmement important en matière
d'investissement de télécommunications
alors qu'il était complètement rihanna
il ya 12 ans parce que j'étais plein de
france télécom
donc donc je pense qu'il est urgent de
revoir notre notre régulation ça n'a
rien à voir encore une fois pour les
acteurs des formidables entrepreneurs
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour les
entrepreneurs français j'aime beaucoup
de respect pour iliad et free qui sont
des entrepreneurs je les dis qu'ils
saisissent les opportunités très
intelligemment
sfr s'est bien développé
wigan générer l'innovation notamment en
étant très rapprochées très très
rapprochés avec docomo au japon pour ici
là mais d'après les innovations et les
synergies qui vont bien mais aujourd'hui
force est de constater qu'on a quand un
système il n'est pas du tout du tout
adapté à nos enjeux et donc l'idée temps
là on a essayé d'en parler avec le
régulateur national parlé avec monsieur
sidi tennis il a une mission
malheureusement j'avais été le ministre
qui avait porté le dirai quand on a
fusionné on a créé l arcep avec
la feuille de route l'émission de
régulateur j'avais bien indiqué que dans
libé l'innovation et l'emploi je vais
pas moins le sentiment qu'il a oublié
l'innovation et l'emploi je pense qu'il
serait bien que le parlement le lui
rappelle
même s'il est indépendante cei monsieur
c'est justement pour compléter votre
peau pourriez vous nous éclairer un tout
petit peu plus précisément sur les
contraintes que vous voyez peser
fortement sur nos entreprises dans le
secteur de ces nouvelles technologies
puisque vous avez été à la tête d'un
certain nombre d'entre elles donc je
pense que vous avez pu bien identifiés
dans le cadre de notamment de la
concurrence mondiale au niveau européen
quels sont les les contraintes et puis
puisque vous avez évoqué l'arcep les
monsieur ainsi qu'annick nous avons
diffusé il ya pas si longtemps que ça
avec l'ensemble des présidents des
autorités de régulation tel que le csa
vous avez préconisé le rapprochement csa
accepte
qu'on attendait vous comment voyez vous
qu'est ce qui justifie pleinement cette
fusion plus que ce rapprochement
on a déjà rapprochés iv la poste
moi je trouve que c'est à ça c'est quand
même assez près d assez proche des
télécommunications est au fond
je pense que
on va vers une concentration
indispensables des opérateurs de
télécommunications par la force des
choses on brasse à lui dire
commencer à le dire en europe parce
qu'on est allé trop loin on va très vite
on va on va le dire en france
comme je connais un peu l'administration
je pense que le travail des autorités de
régulation en france sur les télécoms va
un peu baisser ils vont avoir un petit
peu de temps je pense que c'est bien
qu'on concentre les deux
parler des données tout à l'heure il
s'agit finalement transfert de données
des données
d'image pour les csa et et de son fonds
sont importantes c'est un des aspect des
choses moi je pense qu'on aurait tout à
gagner comme beaucoup de pays qui font
du reste désormais à unifier tout ça
voilà
l'autorité de régulation des
télécommunications
a accompagné
la transition d'un monde où tout ça
était sous contrôle étatique pour le
mettre un monde où tout ça est devenu
plus ouvert et libéral ce passage a été
fait on va maintenant vers une phase de
concentration des
acteurs
l'autorité de la concurrence a joué son
rôle dans cette affaire plus que la
recette du reste on n'avait pas du tout
tendues l'arcep du reste les derniers
débats qui ont animé une partie du
secteur français au cours des dernières
semaines vous avez entendu revanche
l'autorité de la concurrence
donc je pense que pour être très clair
ça ne va pas beaucoup moins de travail
là il veut dire que tu as fait le
contraire à cause de moi je pense qu'il
va voir beaucoup moins de travail
ad gentes l'habitude de réguler un
secteur je pense que c'est bien de les
mettre tous ensemble et
dans la phase d'économie dans laquelle
nous entrons 60e pas inutile
beaucoup de pays le fonde sur les
contraintes qui pèsent sur les
entreprises au delà des simples
contraintes de régulation
j'avais
je vais
je n'ai pas l'habitude de raisonner
comme ça où on est on est en france on a
nos profs aux contraintes on a aussi le
souplesse en à d'ornano il ya d'autres
contraints dans l'autre pays
voilà les contraintes spécifiques au
secteur des télécommunications au
secteur où s'est endettée colis dans
lesquels j'ai pu j'ai plus travaillé
et qui sont plutôt liées à certaines
contraintes du droit du travail en
france elles seront plutôt lié à la
certaine rigidité que nous avons voilà
le le le régulateur en france et moi
lorsque j'étais lorsque j'étais à la
tête de france télécom
le régulateur a fait un travail
d'accompagnement et de transition
puisque c'était la volonté à l'epo dès
17h aider les gouvernements de de
privatiser ces secteurs de le rendre de
l'ouvrir il l'a fait avec tout au plus
tôt
d'intelligence même si évidemment par
définition est régulier quand vous êtes
le plus gros comme c'est le cas de
france télécom il faut le caresser pas
c'est pas facile mais je n'ai pas eu à
l'époque de problème je trouve qu'il ya
eu des dérives effectivement ensuite
quand on a voulu aller beaucoup trop
loin et notamment le cas dans sa 4ème
licence saas et après cela vraiment un
sujet je le redis je leur ai dit avec
force sur les contraintes sans ça sont
des contraintes qui sont liés je pense à
la spécificité de droit du travail en
france à la spécificité aussi de notre
du système du système fiscal
j'avais beaucoup travaillé ces derniers
temps sur système fiscal parlement
beaucoup je les dis le trigger la radio
est celui d'une émission pardon et
bientôt à la fin de ce
qu'il faut faire de publicité mais d'une
chaîne qui s'appelle le vrai faux de
l'info et j'avais indiqué que c'était
quand même terrible parce que au cours
du dernier quinquennat
il y avait eu une disposition fiscale
nouvelle par jour ouvré
je dis bien une disposition fiscale
nouvelle partie vous avez beaucoup
travaillé
malheureusement pour nous mais la
mauvaise nouvelle c'est que ça continue
j'avais été
effectivement une disposition fiscale
nouvelle par d'ouvrer entre 2007 et 2012
mais malheureusement ça continue depuis
2012 et jusqu'à aujourd'hui donc c'est
une contrainte un peu pour nous qu'il
faut s'adapter à tout ça on a énormément
d'admiration pour votre capacité de
travail mais des fois on ne suit pas
toujours
en deux mots vous pourriez nous nous
évoquer le projet lors gens qui lui
pardon tout ceci pour vous dire que le
vrai faux de la foi avait dit mais tirer
votre raison il est peut-être même un
petit peu en dessous de la réalité voilà
c'était voilà
le projet bluekiwi vous pouvez nous en
dire oui le bouquet oui clairement
oui on a on a lancé une initiative dans
le cadre de notre groupe on est 80 mille
quatre vingt mille ingénieurs chez à
tous évidemment j'avais constaté il ya
trois ans de cela que
nos collaborateurs passé beaucoup de
temps à envoyer des emails dans l'e-mail
et d'un instrument qui est un peu
archaïque en tout cas pour les jeunes on
embauche à peu près dix mille personnes
à peu près à dix mille dix mille
ingénieurs par an à tous et donc des
jeunes bovins qui sortent des écoles qui
sont des grandes écoles de cette
diversité pas unique en france et bien
manqué quand on leur donne les outils
vous travaillez outlook pardon de la
publicité ils n'ont jamais vue ils
travaillent sur les réseaux sociaux ou
travailler sur facebook sur twitter
surtout sa maman mais ils sont donc on
avait l'impression d'en donner un
instrument qui était quand même très
archaïque très linéaire hélas
c'est un
dernier rim elles ont reçu premiers
emails lus sans aucune autre critère de
sélection d'importance alors des fois
contre les terroristes gagnent un petit
drapeau rouge il se met à côté vers l'as
raismes ans et même de la sophistication
donc c'est à ce moment que ce programme
très archaïque est très lourd et donc
très contraignant parce que finalement
on a fait une analyse on a regardé mais
combien de temps passez vous sur vos
e-mails internes sujet du mail interne
externe il a seulement extrêmement utile
c'est un courrier électronique rapide en
interne en attendant on a constaté que
nos collaboratrices et nos
collaborateurs passé en moyenne 16
heures par semaine pour lire leurs
e-mails internes
donc ça veut dire pratiquement la moitié
le temps de travail est à ce titre elle
demande évidemment deuxième question
réalise bas combien sont utiles
15% entre 12 et 15% nous on est à la
recherche de la productivité ont fait la
producti on prend de la productivité
l'innovation technologique pour un de
nos clients et donc pour nous aussi donc
c'est dit et du confort aussi parce que
il faut le temps concurrence il faut
écouter les médias qui leur donnait un
environnement de travail qui est
agréable
et
est en fait donc j'ai décidé qu'on
serait la première entreprise au monde
zéro mal on s'est donné trois ans pour
être entrepris 0 mais les rebelles
voulant dire c'est à la belle
voilà donc on a on a on s'est lancé dans
un plan 0 email interne
et c'était il ya trois ans et
aujourd'hui donc on a pris donc on a
essayé de nous d'abord d'évaluer avec la
communauté scientifique que dirige
enfin que coordonne plutôt une heure
tardive puisque c'est moi qui te dirai
oui le suspense était très important que
le patron dans une autre prouesse
technique soit le patron de la recherche
ou patrons j'ai toujours fait ça chez
france télécom c'est la même chose chez
thomson aussi même si évidemment et
surtout de bien plus complet trois
points vous l'imaginez l'allemand fait
quand même c'est important que le patron
m'a dans les dents les aspects
techniques qu'on verse de notre police
technique
et donc donc on a en a on a essayé de
chercher les technologies ça c'est
vraiment laid nos chercheurs nos
collaborateurs qui ont identifié quels
étaient les prix de technologie qui
pourrait nous permettre d'avoir d'autres
systèmes collaboratifs coopératif qui
permettent d'être un peu moderne quoi en
faire donc on a identifié
et puis là on a vu les attraper des
américaines tant pis france et c'est
finalement on a vu une petite start up
française qui s'appelait bluekiwi et qui
faisait des outils collaboratifs donc
qui s'est substitué complètement à
l'e-mail et donc on a acheté cette cette
société on l'a réintégré chez nous on a
développé et aujourd'hui effectivement
on est trois ans après donc on a réduit
de à la fin les à 60%
d'e-mails en moins à la fin de l'année
dernière l'objectif c'est d'être 1 80%
du maine en moins homogène et on pense
que là on atteint le sol parce qu'il y
fera toujours garder un nombre minimum
d'yvel parce que par exemple comme moi
je m'adresse collaborateurs soit une
valeur juridique tout cas vous avez la
lettre l'e-mail donc rien mais donc on
rit restera un socle on pense qu'à 20%
on est très suivi par le gartner c'est
une première mondiale donc le gartner
nous suit et pensent qu'à 20% on a
vraiment le socle voilà on pourra pas
descendre plus bas on aura toutes ont
besoin de 20% du mail classique mais on
a maintenant sur notre groupe on a plus
de 3500 communauté qui quittera bientôt
il y avait du récent article hier dans
les échos sur nan de nos communautés
juridique tout aussi une première
mondiale qui s'appelle rappelé à
l'honnête crois que c'est pareil sur
bluekiwi
c'est absolument passionnant parce que
vous avez donc des sur votre écran vous
avez matin vous travaillez vous
travaillez en fait dans différentes
communautés marketing les yeux risque
vous travaillez aussi se décline sur des
contrats donc sur un contrat on a
plusieurs ont là plusieurs
fonctionnalités dont il ya une
communauté qui s'ouvre sur un contrat et
puis toutes les les compétences sont
dessus et vous voyez immédiatement ce
qui se passe c'est plus et plus de façon
à bêtement linéaire mais c'est au
contraire en fonction de l'importance
sur des sujets qui sont les vôtres donc
c'est un gain de temps absolument
extraordinaire et souplesse une facilité
c'est à travers un double ou bluekiwi
qu'on fait mais on fait aussi avec
d'autres outils comme sharp a une
et d'autres boutiques la messagerie
instantanée aussi la communication
instantanée sur nous sur les écrans pour
pouvoir se parler et puis éviter quand
même ne se parlait de douala de
s'envoyer un email quand on peut se
parler tout simplement y avait beaucoup
choqué c'est qu'on a des plateaux
maintenant sur lesquels on travaille je
voyais un jour je me promenais sur un
plateau et
patron d'une équipe arrivée vous faites
moi je dis bonjour à tous habités sur
son auteur bonjour à tous mais son bail
sur lala lala peut pas leur dire bonjour
comme ça voilà donc si oui on arrive à
un stade où on est quand même on a une
déviance et puis surtout enfin en
matière de qualité parce qu'on est très
très chez atos on est très sensibilisée
à tout ce qui est à environnement
qualité et et du travail donc on aime
on chante qu'on a été on a été
sélectionnée deuxième meilleur employeur
de en france après après eads donc c'est
des choses qui sont importantes pour
nous et donc quand on voit que que nos
collaborateurs passent deux ou trois
heures parce par jour ensuite en
rentrant chez eux pour aller voir comme
ils disent aller faire leurs e-mails ce
qui vous arrive évidemment vous faites
la même chose tout le monde fait pareil
voilà ça on pense que là aussi il ya
sans doute un moment un débordement
qu'il faut qu'il faut il faut se
réapproprier finalement la technologie
pour le faire voir leur passe très très
vite je m'excuse d'ailleurs un peu
monoprix
une dernière
pause et
également oui alors
merci madame la rapportant oui vous avez
évoqué dans le début de votre
intervention la question effectivement 2
de la consommation énergétique un dieu
et de claude et ça m'a mené à une
question il ya les questions de
sécurisation du cloud on parle de deux
cyber criminalité
mais ça des doubles aussi le problème
non c'est à dire quoi si l'alimentation
du système n'est pas garanti ou qu'elle
est concentrée en certains endroits
stratégiques
est-ce que vous avez une réflexion en la
matière est ce qu'il ya des des modèles
qui sont envisagées pouvoir alors je
sais tout ce qui existe en matière de
sécurisation
du clown lui même mais comme vous le
dites enfin aujourd'hui la question qui
se pose où il centra nucléaire est
protégée est un objet cité et objectifs
aux objectifs pardon stratégique si à
côté on met un autre objectif
stratégique
est ce que c'est bien des jouxter ou au
contraire il faut le regarder une
certaine un certain secret une certaine
discrétion parce que demain ça peut être
une source d'attac ou de déstabilisation
important peut-être prendre la deuxième
question comme ça je vous pourrez
répondre à loisir oui moi je vous ferai
d'abord saluer thierry et sa capacité
prospective pour ceux qui ne seraient
pas j'étais un stage
quand il était patron de thomson parce
que je voulais comprendre comment une
boîte qui était à céder aux coréens pour
1 franc
trois ans après avait pu être
reconstituées et cd est valorisé en
bourse à 100 milliards de francs ce qui
était quand même j'allais dire quelque
chose d'assez original pour mériter
qu'on s'y intéresse de seconde donc moi
je serai ces petits ma question et c'est
un peu en complément mais très
différents j'ai lu ces jours ci la
problématique énergétique du stockage
des données des cloud et des data center
etc et c'est colossal c'est un enjeu
colossal et donc il y à des innovations
qui permettrait éventuellement de
récupérer
cette chaleur et de s'en servir
utilement plutôt que de là que de
consommer de l'énergie de nouveau pour
essayer de refroidir et donc est ce que
c'est et crédible
qu'en pensez-vous c
et puis je voulais juste ajouter un
petit un petit message publicitaire à
l'attention de tous dans l'aude nous
sommes en train de développer la
régulation de l'énergie par le stockage
par volant d'inertie si ces technologies
vous intéresse avec un taux de rendement
extraordinaire
pas de département
alors pour la première pour la première
question
c'est évident que quand on opère et ça
revient ça nous renvoie exactement au
travail que nous faisons opéré des
données est traité c'est pas anodin il
faut donc un certain nombre de
d'éléments de régulation de qualité de
service voilà en d'autres termes
s'assurer par exemple si une double
boucle pour les télés pour les télécoms
dont
la trace n'est pas connue
avoir peut-être une
plupart du problème qu'on a du reste en
matière de traitement de données de
sécurisation c'est souvent parce que il
ya une pelleteuse qui arracha câble et
qui fait se fait sauter une boucle ou un
câble électrique lorsque les travaux à
côté a pas cessé c'est bien souvent les
problèmes qu'on a qu'on a qu'on a à
traiter comme atteinte et qui va avoir
des conséquences très très importante
donc c est exactement ce type de
réflexion que nous avons voulu mener
pour dire que quand on opère des données
il ya un certain nombre d'éléments qu'il
faut ce dont il faut assurer
double boucle sécurisation de la mise a
suffisamment d'énergie même si votre
question va au-delà mais je vais y
revenir et puis aussi
redondance
y compris la capacité ce qu'on a nous
dans tous nos deux gros datacenter et on
traite je peux vous dire le nom parce
qu'il est confidentiel et secret mais on
traite des millions d'e-mails de nos
compatriotes de très très très très loin
donc on les traite on a des saveurs dont
on adore on a de très très très loin le
premier
opérateur
en dizaines de millions d'e-mails
aujourd'hui on a des contenus consignes
extrêmement strictes de sécurisation y
compris
en ce qui concerne l'alimentation
d'énergie y compris la capacité si
j'aime bien le moindre problème de
bascule immédiatement sur des
générateurs des onduleurs et des
générateurs nous avons sur site avec
nouveau avec notre fuel qui est traitée
et qui est mesuré et qui est contrôlé
toutes les semaines pour éviter que des
particules qui a propre qui viennent le
bloc et enfin on a désisté lire des
contes des contraintes de sécurité
d'exploitation qui sont extrêmement
sérieuse ce qu on est simplement ce
qu'il faut tout le monde ait les mêmes
et puis il ya aussi la redondance des
sites
pour la quasi totalité des
infrastructures que nous opérons on a
deux sites d alsace il quitte en back up
et quatre enfants quittant complètement
miroir d'un autre et qui n'est
évidemment pas sur le même mieux que le
premier donc évidemment il ya tout ça
et je pense que la delà de 10 rebonds
basse et des sites ce qui doit être
hautement sécurisé qui doivent comme
leçon de stratégie qu'en france je crois
que si on commence à dire ce qu'on vient
de dire on va faire beaucoup de progrès
par rapport à peut-être d'autres qui
vont venir mathieu lemay bergeaud donné
je me mets hébergeurs de web et puis
j'ouvre ça quasiment demander pardon un
peu d'amour dans mon garage et puis on y
va et puis derrière il peut y avoir par
ce moment on a des applications de plus
en plus sensibles à nos pères nous les
secteurs le secteur bancaire on est le
premier opérateur européen en matière de
paiement électronique
donc on opère pour déplier entier attend
que la belgique est quasiment
entièrement opéré par nous on a eu
c'était public on a eu un problème il ya
juste avant noël on a tous nos systèmes
problèmes d'infrastructures si son qui
sont tombés donc les commerçants 80 %
des commerçants valls qui utilisait les
cartes de lima pouvait plus la veille de
noël en quelques heures même pas
quelques minutes puisque en fait c'était
une heure vingt on a toujours fait
basculer sur un autre site qui était
complètement miroir du premier et qu'il
a permis finalement de limiter voilà
donc on a on a ça arrive rarement ça
arrive une fois tous les dix ans
d'arriver bien sûr mais je dirais les
opérateurs privés et en opère des règles
qui nous ont été fixés par nos clients
ou par parler je vous donne pas les les
contraintes que nous avons quand on
opère pour le gouvernement chinois de
hong kong à des contraintes extrêmement
suite quand on opère pour les services
français pour la défense
britannique pour la défense allemande à
des contraintes extrêmement strictes
donc on suit ces contraintes encore
faut-il qu'elles existent ce que nous
voulons dire c'est que désormais avec le
cloud vous pouvez mettre toutes sortes
de données des stratégies coude et non
stratégiques donc il faut
vraisemblablement on passe à ce système
de régulation
de contrôle identique pour tout
simplement vous opéré par mode cloud
parce que vous ne savez pas ce qu'il ya
dessus il ya certainement des éléments
qui sont extrêmement sensibles et
précieux pour les personnes ou les
clients pour le compte desquels vous
vous opérez voilà et puis pour la tania
question de sénateur adnot donc
si c'est certain que en matière
énergétique c'est ses adversaires bien
d'al ain en jeu absolument essentiel je
lui ai dit tout à l'heure
bon
parenthèse puisque tu as fait ton stage
chez thomson à l'époque le jour où je
suis arrivé chez thomson j'ai appelé mon
premier client qui était darty et je lui
dis je vous connais pas mais je voulais
faire un stage chez vous il est pendant
une semaine alors président de thomson
je suis allé vendre des téléviseurs g8
veste rouge thierry stagiaires pour
pouvoir apprendre précisément ce qui se
passe est licite et secret gelé comme
quoi les stages c'est dans les deux sens
à
voilà donc donc la question c'était sur
la sur l'énergie
et encore un peu plus sur leurs
agissements ce de manière à pouvoir
facilement l'énergie et et faire en
sorte que d'une charge on en fasse un
profit c'est une c'est une excellente
question dans des groupes comme
schneider par exemple le font maintenant
beaucoup il ya effectivement tout un
champ de recherche puisque évidemment ce
qui coûte cher c'est le refroidissement
dans le dans la gestion des data center
pour
on est encore on est à la limite de la
loi de moore 1 par parenthèse donc ça
veut dire qu'on est on est maintenant au
coeur au coeur on peut pas réduire trop
maintenant la concentration des
processeurs qui sont intégrés sur une
puce contenu de l'échauffement on est
tellement compacte de l'atome que
l'échauffement à devient absolument
gigantesque et ses deux essais de fin
qu'on commence à rencontrer justement la
militarisation donc au refroidissement
devient devient un enjeu absolument
essentiel mais je suis complètement
d'accord et un groupe pour moi le groupe
qui a le mieux intégré tout ça c'est
schneider electric on travaille dur est
avec eux ils ont ils ont énormément
d'innovation c'est un sujet c'est un
sujet essentiel mais on voit que cette
question du refroidissement est une
question essentielle trouver les
économies on voit un certain nombre de
grands acteurs américains qui disent en
nous par exemple on a data center qui
est extrêmement moderne qui tu as
en finlande
parce que précisément on a accès à des
refroidissements dans les fjords voilà
deux
pour pour ensuite je fais les bills par
exemple par exemple voilà alors là bon
ça ça je ne sais pas je ne sais pas si
si ceux ci
personnellement des personnes qui ont
pensé en tout cas c'est passé comme
c'est pas mieux le projet en tout cas
c'est un vrai sujet l'extraction de la
chaleur dans les datacenters et donc la
consommation d'énergie est un sujet mais
même des projets de barge géante sur
lesquelles on va voir le fer pour enfin
briller de projets mais on arrive
toujours la même chose à partir du
moment où on double au double le nombre
de données générées par l'humanité tous
les 18 mois et que fait unique une
première dans l'histoire humaine
on les stocke on peut les retrouver
advitam eternam bah ça pose tout un tas
de questions physiques mais aussi
morales et politiques
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
échanges passionnants
ya peut-être une question où on n'a pas
le temps de l'évoquer malheureusement le
pensant que les données c'est important
mais aussi la question de la neutralité
du net qui est un vrai sujet c'est à
toute autre question que je suis ça
c'est assez
je suis tout à fait d'accord mais une
prochaine fois peut-être merci
voilà pour l'audition de thierry breton
l'ancien ministre de l'économie qui est
aujourd'hui le président d'atos géant
mondial de l'informatique on passe tout
de suite à l'audition d'olivier iteanu
qui lui représente isoc france internet
society france ils s'intéressent
notamment à la place de l'europe dans la
gouvernance mondiale d'internet
bien d'écouter merci beaucoup d'être
c'est moi qui remercie vous êtes avocat
la cour d'appel de paris vous êtes
professeur apparaît 11
l'enseigné étudie et commentez le droit
du numérique ont je crois que votre
contribution va être très utile au
travail de cette mission dont je vous
laisse immédiatement la parole peut être
pour nous aider à mieux comprendre ce
que sont les enjeux juridiques du sujet
que nous traitons est comme suit pour
répondre à nos questions
disant merci donc effectivement je veux
qu'à plus 25 ans
j'ai dédié mon activité au droit des
technologies de l'information dès
l'origine et pour peut-être préciser un
peu mon ma présentation effectivement
vous l'avais dit je chargé
d'enseignement eh bien ce n'est pas rien
assure bob en master 2 droit du
numérique puisque dénonçons compliqué
maintenant en politiques publiques et
propriété intellectuelle et à paris aux
endroits des communications
électroniques internes voilà dans un
master 2 qui est le seul en europe il
faut le savoir qui est dédié au droit
des télécoms voilà donc droit des
endroits de l'espace et les télécoms
c'est c'est le seul qui existe en europe
pareilles 11 et de ce point de vue a
toujours très très très en avant soit là
donc j'ai écrit à centre de bouquins
dont le premier droit français en avril
96 qui s'appelait internet et le droit
voilà j'ai pas trouvé à l'époque
d'éditeurs juridique les faits chez
eyrolles que j'ai pas quitté depuis
voilà donc la gouvernance puisque c'est
votre mission donc je les rencontre est
d'abord en ma qualité de président de
l'isoc du chapitre français disent 'ok
france
de 2000 à 2003 et puis
ceci faisant cela parce qu'il ya une
cooptation très forte et puis on a
tendance à rechercher
nos amis américains dont on va
probablement par les marchés ce qui a
priori dans sont favorables de là on m'a
proposé j'ai suivi des travaux de dykan
avant qu'elles soient créés en 98
j'étais à berlin lorsque l'icann a été
été créé à l'époque c'était pas l'icann
et j'étais d'ailleurs mission entre
guillemets commandé par le cigref club
informatique des grandes entreprises
françaises qui regroupe à peu près 140 à
150 des plus grosses entreprises
françaises
il souhaitait s'intégrer dans le
dispositif et que j'ai pu faire désigner
dans un groupe de travail puis j'ai été
désigné dans un comité statutaire de
l'icann ce qui était prévu dans les
statuts qui s'appelait de l'atlas si tu
te dis committee qui donc était un
comité qui était qui devait réfléchir à
la création du lac large dont sébastien
bachollet ici présents a été
représentant jusqu'à encore il ya
quelques jours je crois est présent au
conseil d'administration et on nous
étions deux européens désignés vous
savez qu'il dirige il désigne partage le
monde en cinq continents en cinq parties
et donc pour l'europe il ya toujours un
européen du nord et du sud et nous nous
sommes rattachés lors du sud pourquoi
pas donc l'européen du nord c'était carl
bild voilà donc nous étions tous les
deux
on n'a jamais vraiment plus par laisse
entendre qu'il y avait un bon quart de
bild voilà enfin c'est ça s'est passé
comme ça puis ensuite j'ai été désigné
dans un comité statutaire et c'était la
dernière fois parce que sa demande il ya
une équation économique à résoudre quand
on est à dix câble parce que ceux qui
sont les cadres de fonds a priori que ça
dans un comité qui réfléchit c'est ou
devenir du whois d'espèces d'annuaires
cette base de données
qui
évidemment suscite un certain nombre de
convoitises et j'ai par contre
démissionné en cours de comité parce que
effectivement c'était il y avait le le
responsable des noms de domaine facebook
ou 2 go daddy qui est rdd premier des
premiers unités enregistrement au monde
américaine donc ces gens là ne font que
ça et c'est des centaines de mails par
jour peut-être des dizaines quand même
et en réalité s'il très difficile de
pouvoir faire entrer ses idées dans ce
type de comité voilà donc moi j'ai
évidemment été très intéressés dans par
votre part votre mission nouveau rodez
nouvelle stratégie pour union européenne
dans la gouvernance mondiale de
l'internet je dirais que moi ce qui je
suis peut-être pas capable de répondre
sur la totalité des sujets qui me
concerne mais cette nouvelle stratégie
qui m'intéresse parce qu'effectivement
vous avez du hadj à entendre ses
discours on incrimine beaucoup
le gouvernement américain
bon moi je voudrais quand même rappeler
simplement pour
depuis juillet depuis juin 2013 2 puis 6
et 7 juin 2013 on sait on connaît le
programme prisme
le programme prisme c'est ce sont des
entreprises qui adhèrent ce sont des
entreprises américaines qui adhèrent à
la première novembre 2007 microsoft la
dernière fin 2012 apple ils sont une
dizaine retrouve facebook google
je veux dire par là que incriminé le
goût américain c'est peut-être un peu
facile il y à il ya des véritables
enjeux que les entreprises américaines
ont compris et que peut-être des
entreprises européennes elles soient
n'ont pas compris soit ne peuvent pas
suivre et ça je crois que c'est ça c'est
ça l'enjeu je disais que lorsque j'étais
dans les comités de l'icann je pouvais
connaître quasiment à la seconde le
cours de la bourse concernant cisco
voilà c'est c'était pour dire que ce
sont des amériques des entreprises
américaines ont pénétré l'icann et c'est
peut-être ça le plus important problème
parce que on va parler des données à
caractère personnel bien sûr mais qui
est-ce qui surveille en réalité les
populations c'est pas la haine et ça se
sait google et facebook ce sont des
entreprises américaines qu'on a
autorisés à surveiller les populations
en échange de quoi casser ma vision des
choses on a
on leur a rendu leur a demandé de mettre
la main si vous permettez cette
expression cette image dans le pot de
confiture des données ses aînés ça mais
ceux qui collectent ces données ce qui
surveille et ceux qui font ce marketing
prédictif qui fait que nos vies sont
suivis à la seconde ça n'est pas la nsa
ce sont les entreprises américaines
alors tout ça m'amène à deux
observations
ce sera
j'espère mon apport à 7
à cette commission la vraie question
c'est comment faire émerger des
entreprises européennes me semble-t-il
c'est ça on sent petit de la stratégie
or de ce point de vue là j'ai une
proposition à faire à votre commission
une proposition de réflexion à faire
avec commission il ya deux grands
intermédiaires techniques
au travers desquels on est obligé de
passer pour pouvoir interopérer pour
pouvoir se soumettre au réseau
le premier s'appelle l'opérateur
l'opérateur ex de télécoms jusqu'en 19
sucre en 2004 en europe on parle et
d'opérateurs et télécoms puis les
fournisseurs d'accès internet rejoint la
catégorie on parle aujourd'hui
d'opérateur de communications
électroniques et les second va les
appeler les hébergeurs vous avez les
opérateurs de communications
électroniques
les hébergeurs les premiers ou un statut
ont un statut qu'on retrouve dans le
code des postes et des communications
électroniques qui leur impose de se
déclarer auprès d'une autorité de
régulation nationales l'arcep en france
le défaut de déclaration étant puni
d'une peine de peines pénales à lacets
article 39 du code des postes et
communications électroniques de mémoire
savourer un an et 75000 euros d'amendé
on peut importe il ya des peines pénales
associés
ce statut c'est pas simplement des
formalités préalables obligatoires c'est
la soumission
jusqu'en 2003 un cahier des charges qui
prenait en compte les contraintes de
sécurité nationale parce que les
opérateurs de télécoms ondées
ce sont évidemment des acteurs
stratégiques des pays et qui aujourd'hui
ont un statut qu'on retrouve dans la
partie réglementaire du code des postes
et communications électroniques dont
vous avez des opérateurs qui eux ont des
formalités préalables obligatoires à la
respecter à défaut de sanctions pénales
et qui ont un statut associer des
obligations vis-à-vis des consommateurs
visés de la sécurité nationale david la
défense vis-à-vis d'un certain nombre de
deux d'obligations qui l'a aussi s'ils
font défaut à ces à ces obligations ont
le risque d'avoir leur leur déclaration
alors leur agrément lors leur statut
suspendu voire arrêter et puis à côté de
ça vous avez d'autres
intermédiaires en a parlé qu'ils
s'appellent les hébergeurs on en a eu un
qui vient de s'exprimer ici qui est la
société atos qui eux sont dans une
situation de effectivement de libre
concurrence complète total moi ce que je
remarque c'est qu'il me semble que du
point de vue de l'intérêt national de la
sécurité de la défense
il n'y a plus lieu de distinguer l'un et
l'autre d'ailleurs à terme il est
probable qu'on aura beaucoup de
difficulté de distinguer l'un et l'autre
celui qui offre l'accès au réseau soit
parce qu'il établit où il exploite des
réseaux soit parce qu'il offre de
service de l'accès réseau va être
difficile à distinguer de celui qui va
héberger des données et qui va les infos
gérer etc
or qu'est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui on
voit donc des acteurs libres des
hébergeurs je pense à amazon par exemple
numéro monde qui sont totalement libres
de fonctionner comme bon leur semble
comme bon leur semble
qui
de surcroît souvent soumettre ceux qui
recourent à eux ainhoa étrangères
regardez amazon
j'ai écrit sur mon blog récemment un
article qui dit que
internet est une zone de droit n'est pas
une zone de droit pour tout le monde
parce que dans à la fin des années 90
notamment vous avez un très bon rapport
du conseil d'état conseil d'état qui a
été écrit par un palpitant que vous avez
reçus tout à l'heure et qui a été voté
par l'assemblée générale où le grand
message était de dire elle avait raison
internet n'est pas une zone de non droit
très bien ça c'est vrai que ça a été ça
a été un apport important de ce rapport
puis ensuite c'est devenu un peu une
tarte à la crème mais qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire lorsque l'on à un citoyen
européen etc ont recours à google qui se
soumet aux lois américaines à facebook
qui se soumet à l'eau américaine à
twitter qui se souviennent d'un week-end
et amazon qui se soumet aux américaines
est-ce que internet pour le citoyen
européen est une zone de droit dans ces
conditions là je crois que c'est
difficile de répondre positivement
et c est ce sont des des entreprises et
des services auxquels on a recours tous
les jours donc ces sociétés offre
s'adresse au marché français et
soumettent leurs leur relation plus
casser leur volonté après les juges
peuvent avoir des visions différentes à
des doigts étrangères
donc on a ces gens qui ces sociétés ces
géants du web comme on les appelle
maintenant aujourd'hui qui ces
hébergeurs qui ne sont sans statut
impose est obligatoire ce que je propose
sur laquelle jackie qui me semble être
une idée sur laquelle il faudra
réfléchir c'est que ces hébergeurs à
l'instar de ce qui se passe pour les
opérateurs épouse un régime statutaire
qui est pénalement sanctionnée lorsque
il n'est pas respectée dans ces
formalités préalables aidant c'est dans
sa manière de se comporter et vous
pensez bien que si demain un opérateur
déclara l'arcep osait
et pour se déclarer qu'ils font plus
avoir une présence physique en france
mais osait soumettre aux six clients à
nous arrêterons les noix étrangères
l'arcep tu as ta viendrait immédiatement
l'autorité de régulation des
communications électroniques et des
postes intérêts et immédiatement donc
cette règle paraît simple en terme
stratégique parce que cet acteur là
c'est un acteur stratégique de
l'internet et il est non seulement comme
10 je suis breton à l'instant le
détenteur des données de l'ensemble de
la population mais mais il est encore
une fois un acteur qui est qui est
incontournable donc pourquoi ne pas
c'est une chose assez simple et ça
permettrait je pense à une
à une catégorie d'acteurs européens
d'émerger pourquoi ne pas imposer aux
hébergeurs une la soumission un statut
cetc
c'est ce que je comptais vous apporter
comme message peut-être en introduction
avant qu'on échange sur sur ces
questions mais ça me paraît une voie à
explorer j'allais chanon j'ajoute de
surcroît que ce régime existe déjà pour
des données de santé puisque vous savez
qu'en matière de données de santé la loi
impose aux hébergeurs un agrément qui
est délivrée par le ministère de la
santé et j'ajoute enfin que ce plan le
droit de la concurrence personne n'a
jamais trouvé a rien à redire au fait
que les autorités que les que les états
membres impose au niveau national
l'adhésion à un statut obligatoire et
pénalement sanctionnés lorsqu'ils n'est
pas respectée donc ça me parait
effectivement une mesure radicale mais
ne pas répondre dans le contexte prisme
à ce qui me paraît être un tsunami quand
même savoir ce qu'on a appris de de la
collaboration entre ces géants du web et
l'état américain pour des motifs
d'ailleurs qu'ils sont
parfaitement légitime quand il s'agit de
lutter notamment contre le terrorisme ce
qui nous intéresse tous mais c'est quand
même tout de même la boîte noire
je rappelle quand même que le sénat
américain
votre votre correspondant lorsqu'il a
été question de de
reporter le patriot act de cinq ans il
ya des amendements codé déposé par des
sénateurs démocrates qui ont demandé des
garanties pour les citoyens et que le
sénat a refusé de les voter mais donc
cette demande a été présentée par un
sénateur américain voilà ce que je
voulais dire peut-être introduction
monsieur le sénateur et monsieur le
président
de ce que maintenant je suis je suis à
disposition pour toute question
24 de votre votre mission dure des
instances d'arbitrage au ou une
médiation qui multiples aujourd'hui à la
résolution des conflits
de droit sur sur internet pour c'est
vous que il faudrait en créer une
qui soit dédié plus particulièrement
donc
assurer la mise en oeuvre d'une forme de
constitution de l'internet le besoin
s'en faisait sentir
moi je suis très méfiant parce que qui
dit arbitrage médiation dit d'abord un
accès
rémunéré à ce qui est le cas aujourd'hui
à
ces organisations on dirait aujourd'hui
c'est de mémoire ça doit être 1500 $ par
exemple pour régler un conflit entre le
nombre de man et marque mais quand même
1500 de là
en tout cas auprès de l'om pays à genève
c'est ce qu'on paye comme taxes et
ensuite c'est redistribués à des
panélistes à des experts qui obtiennent
ces les dossiers selon des mécanismes là
aussi pas très pas très clair bon
il ya aussi à bout de choses beaucoup de
choses à dire moi je suis très attaché
au service public de la justice je pense
que
et quand je dis service public de la
justice au sens très large du terme
j'intègre une
expérience comme celle de la cnil qui
est intéressante qui n'est pas un
tribunal au sens organique du terme et
qu'il est au sens fonctionnel certes
quand ils condamnent google à 150000
euros ça fait sourire du côté des états
unis mais lorsque la compagne sa d'une
communication publique ça fait beaucoup
moins sourire parce que ces gens là et
je frappe 10 quand même six mois dessus
sont très attachés à leur e-réputation
et c'est là que le bât blesse et c'est
peut-être là qu'il faudrait peut-être
plus faire des choses bon bref pour
répondre à votre question moi je suis
très attaché au service public de la
justice je pense que le vrai régulateur
c'est le juge encore une fois au sens
large
qu'il fait peur qu'il fait reculer
on a eu bon je veux pas en rajouter mais
vous avez une base de données de
jurisprudence qui est legalis.net dans
lesquelles vous avez plus de près de
2000 décision je crois
publiés il souffre j'ai pas mal
participer à ces décisions j'ai vu des
entreprises d ebay ou des sociétés comme
ca reculer devant le juge rappelez-vous
de rodez à la fin des années 90 la feria
ou et les ventes d'un signe nazi
vous aviez un juge qui s'appelle le juge
gomez qui ensuite est passée la cour de
cassation qui s'est intéressé à savoir
il a été au delà de ce que fait un juge
habituellement je vais prendre ma
décision et je m'en lave les mains non
il a décidé à chercher à savoir comment
à des êtres comment on pouvait
exécuter cette décision aux états unis
auprès de yahoo qui était à l'époque un
des géants du web qui a aujourd'hui un
perdu un peu de sa splendeur
il a fait qu'il a convoqué des experts
agences de paris est et au final il ya
ou qu'ils aient fait allumer un
contre-feu en californie s'est soumis
c'est très difficile pour ces géants la
d'être de rester du côté obscur de la
2de de la réalité des choses il supporte
très mal leur e-réputation leur
réputation et le juge ils le voient
comme quelqu'un qui est capable de alors
même un petit juge excusez moi de dire
ça de même un petit juge français parce
que qu'est-ce qu'on pèse au niveau
mondial même un petit juge français qui
rend une décision en france eh bien il
va quand même quelques pas il peut quand
même infléchir et c'est le seul qui peut
le faire un géant comme yahoo je pense
que il faut aussi qu'on ait conscience
de nous mêmes et de nos forces
la principale arme de la cnil c'est la
publication de ces décisions
certaines dans certaines affaires et je
suis bien placé parce que j'ai eu des
cas comme ça où dans ce qu'on appelle le
bit aussi service rendu aux
consommateurs après une décision
d'avertissement pour lui et par la cnil
l'entreprise a perdu 40% de son chiffre
d'affaires dans les semaines qui
viennent puis après la récupérer donc
je
trouver des modes alternatifs de
règlement de conflits comme l'arbitrage
la médiation des procédures
administratives comme si en place en
matière de confinement domaine je suis
extrêmement méfiant parce que ça me
paraît être
d'abord ça représente un coût pour
l'accès aux services quand même qui
était semble-t-il dans la
devrait être dans les pouvoirs galets
régalien de l'état et puis c'est une
boîte noire qui paraît pas toujours
aussi efficace qu'on recompte de 10
quand vous concentrer tous les pouvoirs
comme ça sur un petit vieux basse
évidemment les lobbys sont là c'est
beaucoup plus facile pour essayer
d'influencer les choses lorsque c'est
n'importe quel juge qui peut prendre une
décision n'importe où sas a fait
paniquer cccc grandes entreprises en
tout cas c'est ma vision des choses
pourraient prendre votre question je
suis pas très favorable à une
constitution de l'internet
bon jeu il faut que ce soit une norme
juridique donc qu'elle soit qu'elle soit
obligatoire et ça me paraît
ça me paraît un long chemin aujourd'hui
en tout cas
très bien mais je crois qu'on a grâce à
vous faire tourner ensemble de questions
mais on arrive au terme de notre échange
merci d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
et bien je vous remercie et puis je vous
souhaite bonne chance et bon courage
pour la suite merci à vous merci
voilà pour l'audition de thierry breton
on enchaîne tout de suite sur l'audition
d'olivier était à nos caves également
été auditionnés par la mission
d'information sur la gouvernance
mondiale d'internet
le président d'issos france d internet
society france avait notamment expliqué
la prééminence américaine en la matière